here's I love this cartoon this is from
a underground comic for for people who
smoke way too much marijuana and it's
called these people are the fabulous
furry freak brothers and they were
created by Gilbert Shelton who was one
of the first underground cartoonists and
one of the least pathological ones with
the best sense of humor and he writes
these stories about these stupid hippies
three of them the fabulous furry freak
brothers you see two of them there and
all they do is smoke pot and avoid
responsibility and and run away from the
police and but but it's a nice satire
and so and they have this cat and the
fat one fat Freddy has the cat and
they're too lazy to even give the cat a
name so it's Fat Freddy's cat and it has
its own adventures mostly with like the
an army of cockroaches that lives inside
their like horrible slummy hellhole of a
living place and so anyways it's quite
comical and so the hippies have stumbled
across a small fortune and stoned out of
their minds on cocaine they go out to
set up utopia in the countryside they
buy this terrible piece of property but
they're so deluded that they think it's
like a mansion and they bring their cat
and I don't know if you've ever had a
cat but cats don't like to move it
really bugs them and so they're not
comfortable when you bring them to a new
place they're like the rat that's been
taken out of its comfortable cage and
put into a new cage in the cat you put a
cat in the new room and it depending on
the cat obviously but generally they'll
retreat into a corner and be and meow
piteously and be very unhappy for quite
a substantial amount of time and so the
cartoonist actually mapped this out
quite nicely so the hippie takes the cat
out of the box and says our new home
they're out in the forest this is an
urban cat it's never been in the forest
it doesn't know what the hell's up in
the forest and the cats looking rather
dubiously and thinks so this is the
country and then it's put on the ground
and it starts to slink as you said slink
slink out into the forest and that's
actually what animals do it's a it's a
predator evasion Crouch and so if
they're put in a new territory they'll
hunker down and freeze first and then
they'll slowly unfreeze and start to
explore they sniff first and then
they'll start to move it but they do it
like with trepidation and slowly and try
to hide it so that's what cats doing and
the cat goes out into the unknown far
enough sniffing and all of a sudden Wow
it goes underneath the house just like
the toddler running back to the mother
and the other another hippie there
I think that's Phineas says where'd the
cat disappear to now and the fat Freddie
character says under the house and then
the cats under there in the dark with
big eyes looking terrified saying you'd
hide - if you'd smelled what I did and
so what it smelled was this thing that
has like the head of a wolf and that and
the antlers like a deer and the tail of
a skunk and the feet of a like a chicken
and horrible claws it's like well what
is that well - monstrous amalgam of that
which lurks is not known and so the
cartoonist the comedian got it perfect
said well what is there what is out in
the unknown well you need one
representation not a thousand and so you
take pieces of what's out there that are
relevant and you create a single image
out of that and you say well this is
what's out there and you might say well
no such animal as that exists and that's
actually incorrect an animal very much
animal very much like that exists it's
just a superordinate low resolution
category it includes all those weird
animals that might hurt you that are out
in the forest that's a useful category
weird animals that might hurt you and
that's a real category you know you
might say well there's differentiated
things within that category it's like
yeah every category has that nature it
can still be further differentiated
maybe not protons you know they can even
be differentiated with regards to
location at least so every category can
be further differentiated the question
is whether the category has some
functional utility or at least that's
one of its questions it's like that's
the thing to be afraid of